right now there's 1.7 trillion dollars
of student loans that is held by a
collective sum of about 43 million you
know uh students that ran those up
so
you the the first thing you had is biden
ran a campaign promise when he was not
yet the nominee for president and he was
fighting against the bernie group that
was completely locked in mcburney and
the elizabeth group elizabeth warren and
so he said if i'm elected i will cancel
half of the student loan for the lower
half of more you know uh you know
economically you know below some line
students half of them half of them okay
good well that would be
800 billion dollars and we just approved
a 2.5 trillion dollar debt increase so
where are you going to get the other
half you know 800 billion from it was it
would basically be tarp
for those that are carrying it you know
what the big three are navient wells
fargo and discover hold 40 percent of
the student loan debt so if you're
canceling the debt what you have to do
you have to do something for the ben not
the servicers but you got to do
something for the banking industry and
guess what
that would impact the size of bbb and
that would also impact the size of the
recent increase on the debt limit
because it's all related this 800
billion is going to come from summer
there it is one point seven three and
truly alone yeah and then you'll find in
there about 43 44 million americans that
are carrying that yep 43.2 yep yep so
you there's
a big number so the first problem is
you know i'm not unhappy to see a civil
war inside the democratic party about
this because this is one that all the
all the independents moderates and the
republicans kind of sit this one out and
they're watching the democrats you know
what's starting to happen the civil war
you know what's the problem with giving
things away to people for free you know
what's the problem with giving money or
things away to people for free they just
expect
you eventually have to stop